give me your thoughts on extinction
rebellion
they're really really stupid and bad
elaborate on your thoughts about
extinction rebellion
well because you you come from right you
come from greenpeace co-founder of
greenpeace and extinction rebellion
there there seems to be people could see
some sort of lineage or progression or
connection you know it's an
environmentalist movement
no there's no lineage or progression we
didn't dress up like cult
teams of occult
movement like all dressed in really
stupid looking red uniforms that are
somewhere but a cross between the
inquisition
and uh a cartoon uh
and spraying blood on buildings and
this sort of thing actually
i signed off when people started
chaining themselves to other people's
stuff
um
peace peacefulness pacifism
is non-violence right
but
it doesn't include inciting other people
to violence against you
that is not pacifism
in other words
by you making the first blow or you
chaining yourself to someone's tractor
who is trying to make a living with it
that is not peaceful
and yet
they they were basically saying that
anything short of killing the other
person is peaceful
almost you know it it's not peaceful
to interfere with other people's
livelihoods in a way that threatens
their livelihood that's not peaceful but
they think that they think that this is
a really important and just worthy cause
they need to get attention and people
aren't looking so they need to do more
so why don't they go with the taliban
that would be good then they'd have
machine guns and they could kill anybody
they wanted and have mass murder
uh to destroy the human race you know
that's more or less what they're
recommending as far as i can see
so i think they are i think they are
evil
there are good people and bad people and
people that are sort of in between like
actually most people are a little bit
good and a little bit bad
but these people are evil
that's what i think of extinction
rebellion what about greta thundberg the
other one of the other horsemen of the
environmental apocalypse
yeah well it's funny that people didn't
notice right away that she is a young
girl with pigtails
because uh that's what stalin and mao
and hitler all used young girls
with pigtails
in their photographs that's all been
well documented
um i don't know what the pigtails has to
do with it but uh
dictators all
often
it seems almost always use children
as as a front
to make it look as though
they're nice
i suppose i'm not sure what they're
she's danish though is there's someone
someone in denmark sending her over is
that some totalitarian leader in denmark
trying to get greta thumbberg to
no the movement is totalitarian right
and the movement the movement controls
her
uh green she's she's she's there's all
kinds of photographs of her on trains
with the head of greenpeace
etc i mean and and of course al gore and
the list is endless
and her speeches are written for her
obviously
and she doesn't know anything much about
climate change or science
so what what is she then she's simply a
tool
right she is just a tool nothing more
she is not a wise person
telling us what we should be doing
she is being used
by hollywood actors
and phony politicians like al gore
uh
none of none of whom actually have any
science
what scientist is behind greta thundberg
tuneburg i should say
it sounds like you've got a problem with
the delivery mechanism especially for
extinction rebellion and i can
absolutely agree with you there i don't
think that
going and
hammering and chiseling the front door
of banks or trying to erect structures
in the middle of london bridge i don't
think that that's a fantastic way to get
people onside simply from a human
psychology perspective if you want to
compel people to be a part of your cause
you need to convince them not terrorize
them
that being said yeah yeah but i mean
gluing your breasts to the street for
example has that happened
yes
gluing it gluing
your breasts what like so lying face
down and and gluing your breast to the
concrete so that you can't be moved so
that you're blocking the traffic or
whatever okay right so that that's the
kind of thing they do and i i agree that
it's very sensational and everything but
it has absolutely nothing to do with the
issue whatsoever whatever the issue is i
don't even know what their issue is is
it that humans are should be
exterminated it seems to be that would
be basically their issue
and so i recommended that a man glue his
penis to the top of a of a
subway car
and somebody did a cartoon of it on
twitter as a result of my suggestion
unacceptable words either no no um
you can disagree with their methods but
there is an awful lot of
well-known people who appear to have
credentials saying that we are in a
climate emergency which we are aren't we
no
we are not
in a climate emergency
i don't know people say to me well all
you have to do is look outside
to see that it's a climate emergency i
i'm looking outside and i see a
beautiful green mountain with a glacier
on top of it where i live and a whole
mountain range right next to me and the
whole of vancouver island is as healthy
as can be and yet they say it's been
strip mined of all its trees
no it has not what do you think they
mean when they say climate emergency
i think they mean the end times are
coming
it's just another way of saying we're
all doomed
right because if there was an emergency
it means that if you don't do anything
about it you're doomed it got upgraded
right it was climate crisis and then
within the last couple of years it is
now climate emergency
precisely and i can't imagine what more
extreme word they could now invent
after they've come from
you know
crisis to emergency change
crisis emergency yeah there isn't you
are right there isn't much left but
there's there's so many
differing
critiques around what the impact is that
humans have had on the planet so the
world's getting too hot for instance
increases in the temperature that's
something that's happening is it not
the world has been warming ever so
slightly since about 1700 when the
little ice age stopped getting colder
and started getting warmer
there have been these thousand year
cycles for the last 6 000 years of the
interglacial period known as the
holocene which we are in now which is
about 12 000 years long since we emerged
from the last major glaciation which
peaked 22 000 years ago which was one of
45 major glaciations that have occurred
during the pleistocene ice age over the
last 2.6 million years which is the
first ice age in 250 million years since
the previous ice age ended after a
hundred million years
from 350 million years ago to 250
million years
there was another ice age the previous
one to this one since the last 250
million years until recently
which was 2.5 million years ago
it was warmer than it is now at all
times
it is now colder than it has been even
in this interglacial period
during this pleisoscene ice age which
has gone up and down and up and down and
up and down
in cycles of 41 000 years for the first
1.6 million years and in cycles of 100
000 years for the last 1 million years
in concert with the two milankovitch
cycles
related to the tilt of the earth
changing and the orbit of the earth
changing shape
this is caused by the gravitational
attraction of jupiter on our earth
and so
these people want us to think that the
world began in 1850
when we started using fossil fuels
but for 150 years before that it was
also warming and during one of those
warming spurts because when the earth
warms it just doesn't warm continuously
it goes up and then down and then up and
then down and then up and then down but
net warming
net cooling looks like this down and
then up down and then up down and then
up there's cycles within cycles within
cycles
we understand very few of these cycles
we certainly don't know what causes the
onset of an ice age such as the one we
are in now and we have no idea when it
will end because actually at the bottom
level it is still getting colder
and until we came along
only 150 years ago
we started restoring a balance to the
global carbon cycle by putting some of
the carbon back into the atmosphere
that had been taken out by life
and drawn down co2 to the lowest level
it has ever been in the history of the
planet which is 4.6 billion years
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace